GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY FOR
THIS JOINT OVERSIGHT HEARING
WITH THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
STATE PLAN THIS HEARING IS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW IS A
COMPONENT OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT OR C. S.
B. G. FEDERAL C. S. B. G.
DOLLARS ARE DISTRIBUTED TO
COMMUNITY AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT FOR
CST TO FIND LOCAL ACTIVITIES
AIMED AT REDUCING POVERTY.
DESPITE OUR LARGE ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES TO
DECREASE ITS POVERTY RATE AND
MANY HAVE DIFFICULTY REACHING
AND MAINTAINING FINANCIAL
STABILITY. THE IMPACTS OF THE
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC HAVE ONLY
HIGHLIGHTED THE COMPLEX FACTORS
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO POVERTY
CAUSING INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES TO EXPERIENCE
UNPRECEDENTED HARDSHIPS. WELL
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEES HAVE
MOVE FORWARD LEGISLATION AIMED
AT ALLEVIATING THE CONDITIONS
OF POVERTY. THERE IS MORE TO BE
DONE TO HELP CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLE LEAD TO REACH SELF
SUFFICIENCY. C. S. B. G. HAS
PROVEN TO BE A HELPFUL TOOL FOR
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES USING LOCAL AND
TARGETED APPROACHES. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
THE CREATIVE METHODS HAVE BEEN
USED THROUGH THE PAST YEAR TO
ENSURE THAT THIS FUNDING
PROVIDED. IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
THOSE IN NEED. THANK YOU AGAIN
TO EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE WITH
US TODAY TO DISCUSS THIS
CRITICAL PIECE OF FUNDING AND
THE INNOVATIVE SERVICES THAT C.
S. B. G. FUNDED AGENCIES ARE
THE MINISTRY. I'D LIKE TO OPEN
THE FLOOR TO SENATOR HER TADO
CHAIR OF THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE AND THE
JOINT LEAD ON THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND GOOD
AFTERNOON I WANT TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE FOR HOSTING
THE SENATE. HUMAN SERVICES
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAMBERS TODAY I WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF OF BOTH COMMITTEES
AND OUR PANELISTS WHO HAVE
COLLABORATED TO PULL THIS
HEARING TOGETHER. I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING WITH
SEVERAL OF OUR PANELISTS AS
PART OF THE COLLABORATION AND I
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THIS WILL
BE AN INTERESTING AND
INFORMATIVE. HEARING THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
TO REVIEW THE STATE'S PLAN FOR
THE FEDERAL COMMUNITY SERVICES
BLOCK GRANT WHICH IS. A LITTLE
KNOWN BUT DECADES OLD FEDERAL%
ANTI POVERTY PROGRAM. AS CHAIR
OF THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE I AM DEDICATED TO THE
CAUSE OF FIGHTING POVERTY. BUSH
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO SHELTER
NUTRITIOUS FOOD HEALTHCARE AND
OTHER BASIC. NECESSITIES OF
LIFE. SADLY ACCORDING TO SOME
ESTIMATES THIRTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE ARE LIVING AT OR NEAR
POVERTY AND ABOUT ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN DEEP
POVERTY. ADDITIONALLY WITH OVER
A HUNDRED SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION IN
THE COUNTRY ACCORDING TO THE
FEDERAL TWENTY TWENTY POINT IN
TIME COUNT. WITHIN THIS
HOMELESS POPULATION OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND
ARE UNSHELTERED. AND OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND ARE
PEOPLE. IN FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN. THIS DATA WAS
COLLECTED AND REPORTED WAS
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC SO I EXPECT
THAT THESE NUMBERS TO BE EVEN
HIGHER TODAY. THESE NUMBERS ARE
TROUBLING AND I REMAIN
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED WITH THE
IMPACT OF DEEP POVERTY ON OUR
CHILDREN AND OLDER ADULTS. WELL
THERE ARE MANY FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCALLY OPERATED PROGRAMS
THAT FIGHT POVERTY S. THE C. S.
B. G. IS SOMEWHAT UNIQUE IN
THAT FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE
PROVIDED AS A BLOCK GRANT WITH
THE EXPECTATION THAT LOCAL
PROVIDERS. WILL DETERMINE HOW
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE SPENT WITH
CERTAIN FEDERALLY MANDATED
CRITERIA. KEY AMONG THOSE
CRITERIAS THAT MEMBERS OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIND THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND C. S. B. G.
FUNDS ARE USED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT ARE DEVELOPED AND
OFFERED IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO
COMMUNITY NEED. LOCAL ENTITIES
WERE REQUIRED TO MEET PROGRAM
OF FISCAL STANDARDS ARE GIVEN
THE FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE
THE TYPE OF SERVICES THAT ARE
MOST NEEDED WITHIN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. C. S. B. G. FUNDS
AN ARRAY OF SERVICES RANGING
FROM MEETING THE BASIC HUMAN
NEED FOR FOOD. TO MORE COMPLEX
NEEDS LIKE AVOIDING
HOMELESSNESS. OR HELPING
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FIND HOUSING.
ADDITIONALLY THE FLEXIBILITY OF
C. S. B. G. ALLOWS ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES TO BE NOBLE DURING A
CRISIS. DURING OUR LAST YEAR'S
BG HEARING WE HEARD FROM LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT RESPONDED TO THE
MASSIVE FIRES AND HOW C. S. B.
G. FUNDS WERE USED TO PROVIDE
FOOD SHELTER AND OTHER BASIC
NECESSITIES. TODAY EXPECT WE
WILL HEAR MORE ABOUT HOW C. S.
B. G. FUNDS WERE RECENTLY USED.
TO RESPOND TO LOCAL NEEDS DUE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THUS I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
MORE ABOUT HOW OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY
AGENCIES ARE RESPONSIVE TO
COMMUNITY NEEDS AND HOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT WORKS
TO SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS WHILE
ALSO OVERSEEING. PROPER
ADMINISTRATION OF PRECIOUS
FEDERAL DOLLARS IN PARTICULAR I
AM INTERESTED IN HEARING MORE
ABOUT HOW COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES ARE RESPONDING TO THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
INCREASING NEED FOR NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE AND CHANGES TO THE
FOOD DELIVERY SYSTEMS AND THE
NEEDS OF MIGRANT FARM WORKERS
AND MEMBERS OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HER TADO. I'D LIKE TO
NOW OPEN THE FLOOR- FOR ANY
OPENING REMARKS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. COMMITTEES. NOW
OKAY- WELL THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING- I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR FIRST PANEL WILL PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT AND THE.
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE A
STATE PLAN- OUR FIRST PANELIST
IS THE DAVID SCRIBNER DIRECTOR
OF- CST. AND I BELIEVE HE'S
JOINING US ON WEBEX. I HAVE
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER HER TALK
ABOUT HER TADO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT. RESHARE
COMMITTEE IT'S GIVEN US THE
PLATFORM TODAY. TO SHARE OUR
STATE LEVERAGES FEDERAL C. S.
B. G. FUNDING TO ADDRESS
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA. DAVID
SCRIVNER DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT ALSO
KNOWN AS CSD. I WAS RECENTLY
APPOINTED DIRECTOR BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IN JULY AFTER SERVING AS
ACTING DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
COUNSEL. THE MISSION OF CST IS
TO REDUCE POVERTY. WE DO THIS
BY ADMINISTERING COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND ENERGY PROGRAMS
THROUGH A NETWORK OF LOCAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS. TO DELIVER
SERVICES THAT HELP LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ACHIEVE AND
MAINTAIN ECONOMIC SECURITY.
MEET THEIR HOME ENERGY NEEDS
REDUCE THEIR UTILITY COST
REDUCTION EFFICIENCY UPGRADES
AND ACCESS TO CLEAN RENEWABLE
ENERGY. IN ADDITION TO THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
SHE IS THE ADMINISTERS THE
FEDERAL LOW INCOME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. US
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY'S
WEATHERIZATION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. AND CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
WHICH REDUCES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS RESIDENTIAL ENERGY
COSTS AS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS. CSD ALSO
PARTNERS WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO ADMINISTER GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY BASED OUTREACH TO
RAISE AWARENESS OF VITAL AND
ANTI POVERTY TAX BENEFITS. SUCH
AS THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT. AND CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS. SINCE THE ALSO
ADMINISTERS TO NEW ENERGY
PROGRAMS THE FIRST OF WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT
PROGRAM OR CAP WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED BY GOVERNOR NEW
SOME OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
STATE BUDGET. DEDICATES ONE
BILLION IN FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDING TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIANS ENERGY
BILLS. THE SECOND PROGRAM THE
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD WATER
SYSTEMS PROGRAM MORE LIGHT WHAT
WAS ESTABLISHED BY CONGRESS IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY.
FUNDED BY A ONE TIME ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION. TO HELP HOUSEHOLDS
PAY FOR WATER AND WASTEWATER
UTILITY BILLS. AS A LEAD STATE
AGENCY DESIGNATED TO RECEIVE AN
ADMINISTER CSPD FUNDING CST
WORKS WAS SIXTY NONPROFIT AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. KNOWN AS THE S. B. G.
AGENCIES. C. S. B. G. AGENCIES
OFFER A WIDE RANGE OF SUPPORT
SERVICES IN EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. INCLUDING HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION INCOME
SUPPORT MANAGEMENT HEALTH
NUTRITION MERCHANT SERVICES
SUCH AS DISASTER RELIEF. PUBLIC
NINETEEN RESPONSE EFFORTS AND
MORE. OF THE SIXTY C. S. B. G.
AGENCIES THERE ARE CURRENTLY
FIFTY TWO COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES FOR MIGRANT SEASONAL
FARMWORKERS AGENCIES THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO FARMWORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AT THREE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
OUR CALIFORNIA NATIVE
POPULATIONS. JUST BE G. IS A
UNIQUE FUNDING SOURCE FOR A
VARIETY OF ANTI POVERTY
SERVICES. THE FUNDING IS
FLEXIBLE BY DESIGN TO EMPOWER
LOCAL C. S. B. G. AGENCIES TO
DELIVER SERVICES THAT BEST
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS AND
PRIORITIES OF CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. THAT MAKE A
MEASURABLE IMPACT ON THE CAUSES
AND CONDITIONS OF POVERTY. AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY COMMUNITY HAS A VOICE AND
WHAT SERVICE IS LOCAL C. S. B.
G. AGENCIES PROVIDE. THE C. S.
B. G. ACT REQUIRES AGENCIES TO
BE GOVERNED BY A TRIPARTITE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. IS THE ONE
THIRD ELECTED PUBLIC OFFICIALS
OR THEIR DESIGNEES. AT LEAST
ONE THIRD LOCAL LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WITH THE
REMAINDER OF THE BOARD
REPRESENTING BUSINESS LABOR
RELIGIOUS HUMAN SERVICES
EDUCATION OR OTHER MAJOR GROUPS
AND INTEREST IN THE COMMUNITY
SERVER. C. S. B. G. AGENCIES
ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO DEVELOP
AND SUBMIT A COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. IS ASSESSMENTS ARE
INFORMED BY THE DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT OF LOCAL LOAN LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS. TO PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF THE
CAN THE CONDITIONS FACED BY
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS IN EACH
AREA. THESE COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS ARE SUBMITTED EVERY
TWO YEARS BY AGENCIES AS PART
OF THEIR COMMUNITY ACTION PLAN.
THE DETAILS SERVICE DELIVERY
STRATEGIES AND ADDRESSES
FEDERALLY MANDATED PROGRAMMATIC
ASSURANCES. IT IS THIS
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT INCLUDING
ENGAGEMENT WITH LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS THAT AFFORDS THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS ASSESSMENTS AND
ULTIMATELY THE COMMUNITY ACTION
PLANS BUT ESTABLISH THE BASIS
OF THE C. S. B. G. STATE PLAN.
WELL NO TO COMMUNITY ACTION
PLANS ARE EXACTLY ALIKE
PROBABLY SPEAKING THE MOST
COMMON NEEDS THAT ARE C. S. B.
G. AGENCIES HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
STATE PLAN THAT THEY WILL
ADDRESS OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. OR FOUR DOUBLE HOUSING.
FOOD INSECURITY EMPLOYMENT
UTILITY ASSISTANCE MENTAL
HEALTH AND FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
TRAINING. AS THE STATE LEAD
AGENCY CST IS COMMITTED IN THE
STATE PLAN TO SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA'S NETWORK OF C. S.
B. G. AGENCIES. WITH TRAINING
COORDINATION AND CAPACITY
BUILDING. SUPPORTING THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL AND STATE STAFF. AND
IMPLEMENTING NEW TECHNOLOGY
ENHANCEMENTS TO INCREASE
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCY. SHE
IS THE WILL ALSO CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE EMERGENT SOCIAL ISSUES
THAT IMPACT CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE LOW INCOME POPULATIONS.
AND SUPPORT LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL
CHALLENGES. TWENTY FOUR C. S.
B. G. UNDER THE ANNUAL GRANT IS
REMAIN STABLE AT SIXTY FIVE
MILLION FOR FISCAL YEARS.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED
ACCORDING TO STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW AND LOW INCOME POPULATION
U. S. CENSUS DATA FOR EACH
COUNT. 90% OF C. S. B. G.
FUNDING IS ALLOCATED DIRECTLY
TO SEE S. B. G. AGENCIES WITH
THE REMAINDER FOR STATE
ADMINISTRATION TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TARGETED INITIATIVES.
RATIONALLY 84% IS ALLOCATED TO
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES 11%
OF MIGRANT SEASONAL FARMWORKERS
AGENCIES. AND 4% TO NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS.
JUST BE G. OUTCOMES ARE
REPORTED PER CALENDAR YEAR AND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
REPORTS SERVING OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. THIS INCLUDES
SERVING APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
CHILDREN. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND SENIORS EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND FORTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO LACK HEALTH
INSURANCE. AMONG THE SERVICES
THAT C. S. B. G. AGENCIES
PROVIDED INCLUDE. HOUSING
ASSISTANCE INCLUDING TEMPORARY
SHELTER IN HOUSING PLACEMENT.
WOMEN SERVICES THAT TRAINED IN
PLACE CALIFORNIANS AND NEW
APPROVED EMPLOYMENT.
EDUCATIONAL AND COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH PARENTS AND FOOD
AND NUTRITIONAL SUPPORT AND
ENABLE THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THIRTY FIVE MILLION MEALS AND
FOOD PARCELS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ALONE. IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALLOCATED AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SUPPLEMENTAL C. S.
B. G. FUNDS REPAIRS AT. TO
ADDRESS THE CONSEQUENCES OF
INCREASED UNEMPLOYMENT AND
ECONOMIC DISRUPTION DUE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN THEM DAMMIT.
INITIAL FUNDING FROM THE CARES
ACT ENABLED C. S. B. G.
AGENCIES TO RETHINK HOW TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. ARE FOLLOWING
STATE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES. EARLY ON DURING THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. JUST BE
G. AGENCIES QUICKLY PIVOTED TO
REMOTE WORK AND NEW SERVICE
DELIVERY STRATEGIES TO MEET THE
INCREASED DEMAND. INCLUDING THE
OPERATION OF DRIVE THROUGH FOOD
BANKS CONDUCTING REPORT REMOTE
APPOINTMENTS AMONG OTHER
ADJUSTMENTS. SHE ALSO ALLOCATED
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE PROCUREMENT DISTRIBUTION OF
ESSENTIAL SUPPLIES. INCLUDING
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THROUGHOUT THE C. S. B. G.
NETWORK. PRODUCTIVE
PARTNERSHIPS AT EVERY LEVEL ARE
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
C. S. B. G. PROGRAM. AND I'M
PLEASED TO INTRODUCE A FEW OF
THOSE PARTNERS HERE TODAY.
BRISENO'S FROM CAL CAP ON OUR
C. S. B. G. AGENCIES WILL SHARE
THEIR STORIES AND INSIGHTS.
INTO THE VERY IMPORTANT WORK
TAKING PLACE TO KEEP CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES ON THE PATH TOWARD
ECONOMIC SECURITY WILL BE. EVEN
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES.
AS THE NEW DIRECTOR OF CST I'M
INSPIRED BY THEIR STORIES I
HOPE YOU WILL BE. AND I'M
ENERGIZED AS I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CST AND IT'S U. S. B.
G. AGENCIES. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
YEAR'S BG STATE PLAN. RESHAPE
YOUR ON GOING SUPPORT OF C. S.
B. G. HERE IN CALIFORNIA I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DAVID- READY TO HEAR
FROM OUR NEXT PANELIST- DAVID
KNIGHT IN CALCUTTA. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO THE
JOINT COMMITTEE AND CHAIRS
SOUTHERN ATTARDO AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON
PROVIDING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY ACTION PARTNERSHIP
ASSOCIATION KNOWN AS CAL KAPPA
TO SPEAK REGARDING THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
AND THE STATE PLAN GREAT TO SEE
YOU BOTH ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GUIDANCE I'M DAVID NOT
A SERVICE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CAL CAP OF OUR ORGANIZATION
SERVES AS A MEMBER ASSOCIATION
FOR SIXTY C. S. B. G. ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES. TO PROVIDE TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
STATEWIDE COMMUNICATIONS AND
POLICY DEVELOPMENT OUR
SITUATION ALSO LEADS THE WAY IN
SEARCH OF THE LEAD STATE OR
REGIONAL PERFORMANCE NNOVATION
CONSORTIUM FOR THE UNITED
STATES HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES C. S. B. G. REGENON
THIS MEANS THAT CALIFORNIA CAL
CAPITOLE THE REGION WHICH
INCLUDE THE STATE OF ARIZONA
NEVADA HAWAII THE PACIFIC
ISLANDS IN AREAS OF TRAINING
INTO TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE REGION WIDE.
COMMUNICATIONS AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT. CALIFORNIA MEDIA
ACTION DOESN'T JUST LEAD IN THE
REGION. IT ALSO LEADS
NATIONALLY WITH TWO OF OUR
AGENCIES EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
WHO ALSO SERVE ON THE CAL CAPA
BOARD OF DIRECTORS SERVING ON
THE NATIONAL BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR OUR NATIONAL COMMITTEE
ACTION PARTNERSHIP OF
SOCIALITE. SOCIAIS ASIAN. AS
WELL AS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SEE IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SERVING ON THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION. OF STATE COMMUNITY
SERVICES PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE ACTIONS AND C. S. B.
G. ELIGIBLE ENTITIES HAVE LONG
BEEN LEADERS IN THE NATIONAL
COMMITTEE ACTION MOVEMENT FOR
DECADES. WE'RE OFTEN STILL
SOUGHT AS THE VOICE CAN MEET
ACTION. ACROSS THIS NATION.
WHAT THE COMMUTER SERVICE BLOCK
GRANT CELEBRATES FORTY YEARS
THIS YEAR. THE COMMITTEE ACTION
MOVEMENT IS FIFTY SIX YEARS
STRONG. WATER RELIES ON DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IN EACH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THE COSTLY THRIVES
TO ADAPT TO THE EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE OF OUR FAMILIES. AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. BEING A
PARTNERSHIP THE CALIFORNIA CST
IS SERVING AS A LEAD
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION FOR ALL
AGENCIES STATEWIDE. CALC KEVIN
HAS THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE A MEASURE THE LANDSCAPE OF
OUR GREAT STATE. THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. WELL
YOU HEAR MASS TESTIMONY TODAY
ABOUT THE FAMILIES WE SERVE HOW
AGENCIES HAD A GREATER NEED. TO
THEM THAN EVER BEFORE DURING
THIS UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT.
IS VITAL TO LEADING OUR
COMMUNITIES ON THE PASSIVE
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
ALL WAS STILL SERVING OUR
FAMILIES LOW INCOME DIRECTLY.
COMEDIA ACTION IS BUILT ON THE
PREMISE OF WHAT YOU DO FOR US.
MUST INCLUDE US WE'RE NOT SURE
THE FOR US. OUR AGENCIES ARE
EXTREMELY KNOWLEDGEABLE OF THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS IN THE COMMUTER
STRAKES. AND HOW TO BEST
COMBINED PRIVATE PUBLIC
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THEY
DEVELOP THRIVING COMMUNITIES.
THEY KNOW WHAT HOUSING NEEDS
ARE PRESENT WHAT WORKFORCE
TRAINING IS NEEDED FOR
BUSINESSES TO THRIVE AND TO
EXPAND. WHAT COMMUNITIES LIKE
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH ACCESS
WE'RE LACKING NUTRITION SLOWS
ALL DEVELOPMENT AREAS. OUR
FLEXIBILITY IN THE COMMUTER
SERVICE BLOCK GRANT ALLOWED
AGENCIES TO SERVE FAMILIES NOT
ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO SNAP. OR
FOOD VOUCHERS BUT ALSO CREATING
THE PLACE TO GET THAT HEALTHY
FOOD. IT CREATES ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION VOUCHERS WANT
THE SAME TIME MAKING SURE
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
TO EVEN USE THOSE VOUCHERS.
THEY ADVOCATE FOR EQUALITY AND
EQUITY IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
ACCESS. THE FIVE FOR PEOPLE
THEY DON'T HAVE A VOICE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES WELL THOSE
SAME EXACT PEOPLE ARE THRIVING
WORKFORCE THAT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SUCCESSFUL. ECKEL
DEVELOPMENT IS LED BY CCG
AGENCIES DO THE UNIQUE NATURE
OF OUR AGENCIES. INCLUDING THE
FACT THAT EACH OF THEM ARE LED
BY PROPERTY BOARD STRUCTURE. AS
MENTIONED EACH AGENCY BOARD OF
DIRECTORS CONSIST OF A PUBLIC
PRIVATE IN A LOW INCOME SECTOR.
THIS IS EXTREMELY VITAL IN THE
WAY THEIR AGENCIES CAN BUILD.
DEVELOP AND ADAPT PROGRAMMING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. DIVERSE
LEADERSHIP ALLOW CSG ENTITIES
TO CREATE A SPACE IN WHICH
FAMILY SERVICE. HURDLES
ROADBLOCKS AND EVEN DELAYS. CAN
POSSIBLY BE IDENTIFIED ANDREAS
PROACTIVELY. DURING PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT RATHER THAN
REACTIVELY AFTER THE SERVICES
HAVE BEGUN. TO HAVE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF OPPORTUNITIES
A PROGRAM MUST HAVE TWO THINGS.
FUNDING AND ACCESS AS WE ARE
MORE THAN AWARE FUNDING IS AT
AN ALL TIME HIGH RIGHT NOW
DURING THIS CRISIS. WHAT IS
ALSO EVIDENT ACROSS THE STAGE
DURING THIS CRISIS. INCLUDING
PROGRAMS LIKE EMERGE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. IS THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS
ON INCREASING ACCESS TO THAT
FUNDING. THIS IS MARCY S. B. G.
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES AND THEIR
LEADERSHIP ARE VITAL TO THE
STATE. THIS BG STAY PLAN. BUT
THE FUNDING IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THE TEAMS OF LOCAL VOICES
ALREADY. EXPERIENCING AVAILABLE
TO PUT POLICIES INTO PRACTICE.
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY BECAUSE THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY ACTUALLY ON THE
GROUND IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
THE- YOU'LL HEAR MORE TODAY
ABOUT MORE THOSE SUCCESSES
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC. AS A
COVERT NINETEEN VIRUS REARS ITS
UGLY HEAD ONCE AGAIN
TEMPERATURES RISE CLIMATE
CHANGE IS TRAVELING AROUND AND
HOME BECAUSE RISE. ALL THINGS
ADVERSELY AFFECT PEOPLE'S LOW
INCOME TO MEET ACTION WILL
CONTINUE TO BE CALLED UPON.
CALCUTTA HAS BEEN IS PROUD TO
WORK ALONGSIDE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN CC TO KEEP OUR
NETWORK AT THE TOP OF THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO THE NEEDS
AS WELL AS A LEADER. AS WELL AS
LEAD THE COUNTRY TO WORK FOR
FAMILIES COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
FOR THAT PLEASE SHARE THIS
INFORMATION TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AND GOVERNANCE OF
OUR GREAT STATE. THANK YOU
DAVID. NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
JEREMY TO BIAS THE- CEO FOR CAL
KAPPA. GOOD DAY THANK YOU JOINT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHAIRS
HER TADO AN CALDERON FOR
INVITING US TO SPEAK TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE HEARING ABOUT
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM. MY NAME IS JEREMY TO
VICE I'M BOARD PRESIDENT OF CAL
KAPPA IN CEO OF COMMUNITY
ACTION PARTNERSHIP. OF KERN
COUNTY. THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF CHALLENGES TO WAYS
NONE OF US COULD HAVE IMAGINED
BEFORE WE FIRST HEARD OF COVERT
NINETEEN. THE HEALTH IMPACTS
ILLNESS AND LOSS OF LIFE HAVE
BEEN NOTHING SHORT OF A TRAGEDY.
BUT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALSO FACED AN ECONOMIC
CRISIS CRISIS OF MASSIVE
PROPORTIONS. AND THOSE WITH THE
LEAST HAVE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST.
AND THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE. THERE ARE SIXTY PRIVATE
NONPROFIT AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA WHO
POWERED BY CS BG HELP THOSE IN
NEED EVERY DAY. WE CREATE A
NETWORK OF SERVICES ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. TO
BUILD THE RESOURCES SKILLS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL HELP
MAKE THEM INDEPENDENT STRONG
AND PROSPEROUS. AND THAT'S BEEN
A MORE DIFFICULT MISSION THIS
YEAR FOR SURE. WE HAVE BEEN
BLESSED TO HAVE OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT. TO RELY ON AS WE
FOUGHT FOR OUR CLIENTS THIS
PAST YEAR. WHAT HAS MADE THESE
PARTNERSHIPS SUCCEED IS THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED THROUGH
THE C. S. B. G. PROGRAM.
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES DO
OUR WORK FROM THE STREETS OF
EVERY COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
LABORING WHERE THE NEED IS
GREATEST. WE PLAN AN ADAPTER
WORK TO WHAT WE SEE ON THOSE
STREETS EVERY DAY. AND THAT IS
WHERE THE LOCAL FOCUS OF C. S.
B. G. PROGRAM TRULY SHINES. IS
ADAPTABLE TO EVERY COMMUNITIES
NEEDS THAT LOCAL FOCUS IS
CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS IN THIS
BAKED INTO THE VERY DNA OF OUR
NETWORK. COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCIES ARE GUIDED BY DIVERSE
AND INCLUSIVE BOARDS MADE UP OF
AN EQUAL NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
CLIENTS PRIVATE SECTOR
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS. THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
ARE AS DIVERSE AS THE STATE AND
THEY GET AN EQUAL SAY AND HOW
WE DESIGN AND RUN THE PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE THEM. ANOTHER
ANOTHER CRUCIAL ASPECT OF THE
C. S. B. G. PROGRAM. MAKES THE
FLEXIBILITY I JUST TALKED ABOUT
POSSIBLE AND THAT IS
ACCOUNTABILITY. COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED TO
TRACK OUR USE OF C. S. B. G.
FUNDS. GATHER DETAILED PUBLIC
OPINIONS ABOUT OUR SERVICES
CONSIDER COMMUNITY NEEDS AND
REPORT EXTENSIVELY TO OUR
PARTNERS AT CST. WE MUST SHOW
THAT WE ARE LATE LASER FOCUSED
ON DOING THE BEST WE CAN TO
HELP OVERCOME THE CONDITIONS OF
POVERTY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
MOST OF OUR LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS SINCE THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. AND THAT HAS
HELPED US BUILD STRONG ROBUST
ORGANIZATIONS WITH DEEP ROOTS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AND THAT IN
TURN HAS EXPANDED THE IMPACT WE
HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WE CAN
TAKE ON PROJECTS NOBODY ELSE IS
EQUIPPED TO DO AT THE SAME TIME
WE SUPPORT THE BROADER
NONPROFIT NETWORKS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND FOSTER
COLLABORATIONS THE MULTIPLY THE
GOOD WORK OF EVERYONE INVOLVED.
C. S. B. G. COMPLIMENTS OF
FLEXIBILITY AND GIVES US THE
POWER TO MOVE FAST WHEN CRISIS
STRIKES. NOTHING HAS PROVED
THAT BETTER THAN THIS PAST YEAR.
AS AN EXAMPLE THE CAP K. FOOD
BANK IS THE CENTRAL FOOD
DISTRIBUTION HUB FOR EIGHT
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES OF
TERRITORY IN KERN COUNTY. WE
HAVE A LARGER CITY LAND AREA TO
COVER IN SIX U. S. STATES. AND
WE DO THIS RELYING ON A NETWORK
OF MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
COMMUNITY CHURCHES FOOD
PANTRIES AND NONPROFITS TO GET
THE FOOD INTO THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO NEED IT. SADLY WHEN
THE PANDEMIC HIT ME THOSE
PARTNERS CLOSE OUR DOORS. SO WE
MOVE FAST WE CONNECTED WITH
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOLS AND CREATE A
DAILY DRIVE THRU FOOD
DISTRIBUTIONS AND EMPTY HIGH
SCHOOL PARKING LOTS. WE DID A
CERTAIN ERROR DETERMINATION AND
C. S. B. G. SUPPORT. AT ARE YOU
CENTERS PROVIDING CHILDREN SAFE
SOCIALLY DISTANCE PLACES TO
ATTEND VIRTUAL SCHOOL WAS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WORKING OR
UNEMPLOYMENT ECONOMIC CRISIS
FOR MANY OF OUR FAMILIES. R. TO
YOU CENTERS UCSB G. FUNDS TO
MODIFY DESKS DESKS WITH
PLEXIGLASS SHIELDS AND MOVING
THEM IN THE GYM SO WE COULD
SEPARATE THE CHILDREN. AND KEEP
THEM SAFE WHILE OUR STAFF
SUPPORTED THEM WITH TUTORING
AND HOMEWORK ASSISTANCE. THESE
ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES AND I CAN
PROMISE YOU THAT EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY IN THE
STATE HAS A LIST OF SIMILAR
STORIES. BUT C. S. B. G. THAN
JUST TRYING DURING COVERT
NINETEEN. FUNDS FROM C. S. B.
G. EMERGENCY RESERVES HELP CAP
K. RESPOND SWIFTLY TO A MAJOR
SEVEN POINT ONE EARTHQUAKE IN
RIDGECREST ON JULY FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE UTILIZE
C. S. B. G. EMERGENCY FUNDS FOR
CST TO SWIFTLY GATHER TRUCKS
AND SUPPLIES AND DELIVER TO A
COMMUNITY THAT WAS IN NEED. C.
S. B. G. CAN ALSO BE A CRITICAL
TOOL FOR THE COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY
WILDFIRES. IN CLOSING I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL AGAIN FOR LETTING
US SHARE STORIES AND EMPHASIZED
THE VITAL IMPORTANCE OF C. S.
B. G. PROGRAM. TO OUR STATE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AS YOU REVIEW
THE DRAFT C. S. B. G. STATE
PLAN. IF THERE'S ONE THING
WE'VE LEARNED IN THE PAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. IT'S THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS COMING NEXT.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS WITH THE
HELP OF C. S. B. G. WE WILL
BUILD A WAY TO GET THROUGH
WHATEVER WE FACE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JEREMY I'D LIKE TO
NOW OPEN THE FLOOR TO- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MANY QUESTIONS FOR
OUR PANELISTS. SENATOR PAN. IS
IT THANKS VERY MUCH AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- PRESENTATIONS-
ABOUT- THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS I
DID HAVE A QUESTION IN TERMS
OF- TERMS OF THE PEOPLE SERVE
THAT WAS THE BACKGROUND PAPER
AND- AND I KNOW THAT THE- ME
SERVICE BLOCK GRANT COVERS A
LOT OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES- BUT- AND-
CERTAINLY- ADDRESSES A DIVERSE
POPULATION- BUT I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE. THAT FOR EXAMPLE- IN
THE BACKGROUND PAPER- ONLY FOUR
POINT 9% OF- THE RECIPIENTS
WERE ASIAN OTHER 29% RUN DOWN
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH IS
MIXED IN THEIR SELF- THE GIVEN
THE LARGE NUMBER OF- AND NOW IN
ITS- TERMS OF JUST SERVICE.
DATA COLLECTION IN TERMS OF
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND SO FORTH
IS ARE THERE THINGS THAT- I
MEAN I DON'T LIKE THREE MORE
BURDENS ON. PROGRAMS BUT IS
YOUR BILL IN A WAY WE CAN GET A
BETTER- DATA COLLECTION ON WHO
SERVED. AND MAYBE THAT'S DAVID
SCRIBNER. I THANK YOU YES WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS- AT
THE NEED FOR INCREASED DATA
COLLECTION AND IT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
PRIORITIZED GOING FORWARD NOT
ONLY FOR C. S. B. G. BUT ALSO
ITS ENERGY PROGRAMS WE ARE
WORKING ON THE ON GOING IT
SOLUTIONS TO INCREASE THAT DATA
COLLECTION TO HELP NOT ONLY
REPORT OUT SERVICES NOW COMES-
BUT ALSO TO MAKE- SOLID TO
DEPARTMENTAL LANE AND- DECISION
MAKING FROM R. OR C. S. B. G.
PARTNERS- I CAN'T ANSWER- RIGHT
NOW WHITE THERE IS JUST THE-
THE OTHER- REPORTING ASPECTS OF
IT I THINK IT IS JUST THE
NATURE OF THE REPORTING THAT
COMES FROM. A LOCAL AGENCIES-
POTENTIALLY- GERMANY OR CAL
KAPPA COULD- ALSO AT THEIR
INSIGHTS YEARS WELL- BUT I DO
KNOW THAT THIS IS BEN AND AN
ONGOING EFFORT- NOT ONLY BY THE
DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO THE US EAST
REGION AGENCIES AS WELL TO-
INCREASE THE- DATA COLLECTION.
AND REPORTING. AND PERHAPS- I
DON'T KNOW THE OTHER SPEAKER
WANT TO JUST AFTER SOME OF THE-
OF IN TERMS OF THE DATA
REPORTING AND THEN ALSO
OUTCOMES EVALUATION SO I NEED
SOUNDS LIKE FROM YOUR
PRESENTATIONS AND- BACKGROUND
PAPER A LOT OF. GREAT WORK
BEING. AS YOU TO BE MORE
NIMBLE- SO WE'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN WEIGHING YOU DOWN BUT I
THINK UPDATE FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF TRYING TO. LOOK
AT THE OUTCOMES OF THE
INVESTMENTS- TO BETTER TO
BETTER ARTICULATE THEM I WOULD
TRY TO HELP ALSO AND PERHAPS-
AND IF THERE ARE. SOME COMMENTS
FROM OTHER AND MISTER KNIGHT OR
MISTER TO BIAS ABOUT- THE
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR- EVALUATION AND- DATA
REPORTING. YES THIS IS DAVID
KNIGHT WITH CAL CAP ABOUT BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS. ARE FIRST OF ALL I
DO HAVE EXPERIENCE OF WORKING
WITH OUR NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
WAS ACTUALLY THERE WHEN THEY
STARTED THE DATA COLLECTION
SYSTEM SO. CURRENTLY WE'RE
UNDER THE SECOND MODEL OF THAT
DATA COLLECTION HOW WE DO THAT
NOW THAT IS SET. FROM OCS
DIRECTLY AND HOW THEY DO THAT
THEN WE HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
KIND OF CONTINUE AND EXPAND ON
THAT. AND AS MR STRINGER SAID
WE'RE WE'RE- WHAT. WHAT
ADVANCED HEARING CALIFORNIA HOW
WE DO THAT. SO JUST BASICALLY
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE DATA
AND HOW WE USE THAT WAS FIRST
ALL THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
DO COLLECT IS THE DEMOGRAPHICS.
OF ALL THE FAMILIES OF THE
MAJORITY OF FAMILIES THAT WE
SERVE. THERE ARE PROGRAMS THAT
MAY BE YOU KNOW A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WHERE
SOMEONE'S USING. NO PUBLIC
TRANSIT WHERE YOU CAN GET ALL
THE DEMOGRAPHICS ON EVERYBODY
THAT GETS ON AND OFF OF. A
PUBLIC VEHICLE- BUT FOR THE
MOST PART WE DO COLLECT ALL
DEMOGRAPHICS OF ALL THE
FAMILIES THAT WE SERVE. AND
WE'RE CONSTANTLY COMPARE THAT
NOT JUST TO OUR POPULATIONS OF
YOU WANNA LOOK AT SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE ASIAN POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA- IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT
15% OF THE TOTAL POPULATION. OR
AS WE KNOW THAT IT'S ONLY NINE
POINT 9% OF THE POVERTY
POPULATION ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE PUMP. POPULATION
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SERVE
UP TO THIS YEAR WHICH IS ONLY A
100% OF THE POVERTY LINE. SO
WE'RE ONLY CURRENTLY SERVING
FOUR POINT NINE TO FIVE POINT
2% OF THAT SO THERE STILL IS A
GAP OF FOUR PERCENT. AND WE
WE'RE VERY AWARE THAT
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S HOW WE
POPULATE. OUR AGENCIES THAT WE
STAFF THOSE AGENCIES TO MAKE
SURE THEY WERE IN THE CORRECT
COMMUNITIES. SO THAT WERE MORE
A LOT OF THAT WE CLOSELY WORK
TO THAT. THE OTHER TWO PARTS OF
R. IN REPORT ON THAT WE LOOK AT
AND UNDERSTANDING OUR DATA. IS
BOTH LOOKING AT OUR SERVICE
DATA ENTERED HALFTIME DATA IN
AND HOW THAT MATCHES TOGETHER.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
MAKE SURE WE DO IS
UNDERSTANDING THE PEOPLE TO
COME INTO OUR OFFICE. AND WHAT
SERVICES THEY RECEIVE. AND THEN
ONE OF THOSE TIMES RECEIVE
SERVICES ONE OF THE TYPE OF
OUTCOMES THAT THEY HAVE. WE
LOOK AT ALL DIFFERENT AREAS SO
WE LOOK AT. YOUR POINT WE LOOK
AT HOUSING WE LOOK AT EDUCATION
ALL THOSE MAJOR OUTCOMES. THAT
YOU SEE ACROSS WHETHER YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A WORK FORCE
PROGRAM. YOU LOOK AT A HOUSING
PROGRAM WHATEVER IT MAY BE. SO
WHAT WE DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION IS BILLS SAY. WHO
GOT THE SERVICE AND WHO HAD
OUTCOME AND WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE IN THOSE PEOPLE SO.
IT'S A PRETTY ADVANCED SYSTEM
WE CAN DEFINITELY SUPPLY. THAT
FULL REPORT TO YOU. ULTIMATELY
WE TRY TO DO IS BREAK IT DOWN
SO THAT IT'S A IT'S A SHORTER
VERSION OF THAT REPORT- SO
THERE'S NOT JUST SUCH A MASS
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION. BUT DUE
TO OUR AGENCIES USE THAT
INFORMATION AS A PART OF THEIR
NEEDS ASSESSMENT DISTRICTS
ASSESSMENT. TO UNDERSTAND NOT
ONLY THE POVERTY COPULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT HOW DOES IT CAN.
THE POPULATION THAT WE SAW. IN
SOME OF THOSE OUTCOMES THAT
THEY HAVE. THANK THANK IF I CAN
JUST FOLLOW UP THAT- AGAIN I
REALLY. YOUR ACKNOWLEDGING THE
FACT THAT THE ASIAN COMMUNITY
AND I THINK THE KEY I CAN IS
ONLY REPRESENTS POINT THREE
PERCENT- IT'S REPORTED THAT
HERE IT IS PERHAPS UNDERSERVED
BY THIS PROGRAM- I WAS TO MAKE
NOTE THAT- WITHIN THE ASIAN
UMBRELLA THERE'S TREMENDOUS
DIVERSITY AS WELL SO- PERHAPS
LOOKING AT DISAGGREGATED SOME
OF THE DATA I CAN. I THINK
THERE'S MANY SUBGROUPS- OF THE-
OF THE API COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY- LOW INCOME AND
POVERTY THAT WOULD BE SERVED BY
THIS PROGRAM AND TO BE GOOD TO
KNOW- TO WHAT DEGREE WE ARE
REACHING TO THEM WHAT DEGREES
LANGUAGE ACCESS ISSUE. IN THE
PROGRAMS- TO IDENTIFY SOME OF
THOSE BARRIERS AS TO WHY AS YOU
POINTED OUT- IN YOUR TRIAL YOU
KNOW. THAT- FORTUNATELY- YOU'RE
ABOUT AT HALF OF THE- BOB. IT
COULD BE SERVE- IN THE H. E. I.
SO SO APPRECIATE THAT. BUT LOOK
FOR TO ASSUME YOU KNOW WHAT TO
MAKE HOW WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS
ON IDENTIFIED THE BARRIERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR TO
HAVE ANY OTHER SENATOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. THANK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M GONNA
FOLLOW UP ON OUR POLITICS
QUESTIONS FROM THE SENATE IF I
CAN REGARDING OVERSIGHT. AND
ALL- LOOK AT THE AGENDA IF I
CANNOT AND ON PAGE FOUR FOR C.
S. B. G. ELIGIBLE ENTITIES ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS FOR THEM IS
THAT THEY MAINTAIN A
PERFORMANCE FOCUSED SYSTEM FOR
ASSESSING AND REPORTING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS ANTI
POVERTY STRATEGY. DO IS THERE A
REPORT THAT IS GENERATED FROM
THOSE WHO ARE- SUBMITTING TO
THAT SYSTEM AND WHAT HASN'T
SHOWN- REGARDING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR STATE
DOLLARS IN THOSE. GO AHEAD YES
THEY EVEN HAVE A CAP UP AGAIN
SO THE PREFERRED SYSTEM THAT WE
USE IS KNOWN AS ROMA WHICH IS
RESULTS ORIENTED MANAGEMENT
CAPABILITY IT WAS STARTED
TWENTY ONE YEARS AGO- AFTER THE
GOVERNMENT PERFORMANCE AND
RESULTS ACT. IT'S BEEN SINCE
EDITED UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
WHEN HE DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT
INITIATIVE AND SO WE ARE NOW IN
ROME- WE CALL ROMA TWO POINT OO
SORE THE NEXT GENERATION. SO
MAJORITY OF AGENCIES ACROSS THE
NATION AND ALL THE AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA USE THAT
FORMAT- TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE MANAGING- AND THEY'RE
ACCOUNTABLE BASED ON RESULTS
NOT JUST ON SERVICES BUT WHAT
HAPPENS BECAUSE OF THOSE
SERVICES. THE MAJORITY OF
AGENCIES ALL USE THAT SYSTEM WE
HAVE A WHAT WE CALL PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS- SO THERE IS ROUGHLY
NINETY PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
THAT WERE SET BY THE NATIONAL
IMPROVE BY. FED OCS AND ONE OF
THOSE ARE TWO OF THOSE
STANDARDS. I'LL HAVE TO DO WITH
THAT PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM SO EVERY AGENCY MUST GO
THROUGH THIS PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT. A CHECKLIST OR YOU
KNOW EVALUATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR MEETING ALL THOSE
STANDARDS INTO THOSE STANDARDS
INCLUDES THE USE OF A
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM OR RESULTS
BASED SYSTEM. THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE USE THAT ROAM ASSIST. IS
THERE ANY REPORT THAT IS
GENERATED FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE AS WE
ARE DETERMINING AND LOOKING AT.
A STATE PLAN FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. HOW MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE THAT ONE- YES THANK YOU
DAVIS FROM THERE WAS THE IS
THE- THERE IS AT THIS TIME NO-
OFFICIAL REPORT FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS- THE DATA THAT'S
REPORTED FROM LOCAL AGENCIES TO
SEE S. B. AND THEN UP TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS USED-
REPORT ON A YEAR BY YEAR BASIS.
RIGHT NOW THE DEPARTMENT IS
AWAITING FEDERAL HHS APPROVAL
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY- DATA THAT
WAS COLLECTED SO AT THIS TIME-
WE COULD NOT COMPLETE AT COMPLY
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW SINCE WE
DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY FROM
FEDERAL AGENTS JUST RELEASED
THOSE THAT THAT AT THIS TIME-
BUT AS SOON AS WE DO GET THAT
DATA WE CAN COMPILE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY REPORT.
AFTER THE LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW.
I THINK THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE FOR US TO BE EVALUATING
AS WE ARE CONSIDERING.
CONTINUING OF THIS PROGRAM- I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
INFORMATION IMMEDIATELY PRIOR
TO TWENTY NINETEEN WILL ALSO BE
INFORMATIVE FOR US- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT IF WE ARE
COLLECTING THIS INFORMATION
THAT WE IN THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
RECEIVING IT. I'M I'M GOING TO
TRANSITION NOW IF I CAN'T OF
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS ASSESSMENT
HI THIS QUESTION IS GOING TO
AGAIN BE FOR THE DIRECTOR DAVID
SCRIBNER. IN THE CONCLUSION OF
THE HANDOUT THAT WAS GVEN TO
US AND SAID THAT ALL AGENCIES
HAVE COMPLETED THE REQUIRED
COMMUNITY NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
YOUR WORDS TODAY WAS THAT IT'S
THIS COMMUNITY NEEDS ASSESSMENT
THAT PROVIDES A COMPREHENSIVE
PICTURE TO HELP TO INFORM THE
ACTION PLAN. AND YET WHEN I'M
LOOKING AT THE HAND OUT TODAY
AND THE STATE PLAN WHAT. I'M
READING FROM IT ON PAGE THREE
AS A NEED FOR US TO ASSESS AND
EVALUATE EMERGING COMMUNITY
NEEDS I GUESS MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT SHOWED FROM THAT COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND IS THERE A
REPORT FOR US AS THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE.
REGARDING WHAT THE AGENCIES ARE
RECEIVING NOW I UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR THE FLEXIBILITY IN BY
THE LOCALS. ARE THE ONES TO
PERFORM THIS NEEDS ASSESSMENT
BUT AGAIN I BELIEVE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF INFORMATION
FOR US THE LEGISLATURE TO HAPPY
FOR US. I APPRECIATE THE- THOSE
COMMENTS IN THAT SUGGESTION-
ABSOLUTELY- WE DO NOT HAVE A
REPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE THAT I THINK THAT- IN
THE- STATE PLAN AND I THINK
THAT THE STATEMENT IS MORE
ABOUT THAT THERE ARE. I'M GOING
TO URGENT NEEDS THAT CAN OCCUR
FROM THE TIME THAT COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENTS HAVE BEEN
DONE AND SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT AS PART OF THE STATE
PLAN. THROUGHOUT THE TWO YEAR
CYCLE THAT- THE C. S. B. G.
PROGRAM WILL OPERATE UNDER THE
STATE PLAN AND SO THAT. LOCAL
CCG AGENCIES WILL MAINTAIN
THEIR FLEXIBILITY AND WILL
CONTINUALLY ASSESS THE NEEDS OF
THE LOW INCOME POPULATIONS THAT
THEY SERVE. TO ENSURE THAT CSU
G. FUNDS IF THEY RECEIVE HER
BEING ADMINISTERED TO ASK THE
RESULTS AS A RESULT TO ANY
EMERGENCIES THAT COULD HAPPEN-
JOB RELATED TO WILDFIRES FOR
EXAMPLE THAT WE NOW HAVE-
CLOSURES UP IN EL DORADO COUNTY
THAT COULD IMPACT- SOME C. S.
B. G. AGENCIES THERE- AS WELL
AS- ON GOING DROUGHT. AND SO
WHILE THE STATE PLAN DOES LOOK
AT THE COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS IN A POINT IN TIME-
IT IS ALMOST AS IF A LIVING
DOCUMENT THAT NEEDS TO BE A
FLEXIBLE OVER TWO YEAR PERIOD-
AND THAT THEY THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THIS COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT. AGAIN FOR THE
NEXT PLAN BUT WHY DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT- THE THAT YOUR
DESIRE TO HAVE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE DESIRE TO HAVE A
REPORT OUT OF BY THE DEPARTMENT
OR THE AGENCIES- AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN LOOK. TO-
TO HANDLE HERE IN THE FUTURE. I
ALSO A- WHAT YOU'RE- OF THE-
NEEDS DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
UNITED WAY WAS CONDUCTING. AND
GIVING US INFORMATION ON A WEEK
BY WEEK BASIS BASED ON WHAT
COMMUNITY NEEDS WERE. BUT I DO
THINK THERE'S AN ADVANTAGE FOR
US TO TRACK OVER TIME WHAT HAS
BEEN CHANGING AS WELL AND-
HENCE WHY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU SOMEONE- C. WE
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS- FIFTY
SENATOR JOHNSON JR WITH- OKAY
SENATOR HER TITLE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I MY QUESTION I
THINK IT IS MORE FOR A DIRECTOR
DAVID SCRIBNER- I KNOW THERE
WAS A MENTION OF HOW THE
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED.
AND I CAUGHT THAT- THERE'S 11%
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO 4% AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT-
WHY IS THAT AMOUNT OR THAT
PERCENTAGE DIFFERENT FOR- AND
ENTITIES ANDNOT A WISE AND IT
EVENLY DISTRIBUTED- IT'S MORE I
GUESS FOR ME TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE WAY THAT SEE A
SPEECH HE WORKS BUT IF YOU. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE AN
ANSWER TO THAT. HI THERE THE
SIMPLE ANSWER IS THAT THE
ALLOCATION OF DOG IS OUTLINED
IN THE CODE- AND IT ALSO LOSE
OF A LONGSTANDING ALLOCATION AS
IT RELATES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT-
THE- BEFORE PERCENT- TO-
NATIVE- YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA OF
INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS THAT ALSO
INCLUDES OPIATES- THEY GET A
BASE LEVEL FUNDING AS WELL- IT
IS A BIT OF A COMPLEX FORMULA.
FORMULATION THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
TO SENATOR- IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT BUT IT IS. OUTLINED
AS A AS A CODE SPECIFIC. WAYS
IN WHICH THE THESE DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO BE PROVIDED TO C. A.
S. AND THE OTHER AGENCIES THAT
TO ADMINISTER C. S. B. G. HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. GREAT AND JUST A
COUPLE MORE FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
TO THAT ONE- WHEN WAS THAT CODE
LAST REVISITED- THAT. THAT
ALLOCATES THESE PERCENTAGES STE
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION AND
THE SECOND QUESTION. IS WHAT
IS. 11% AND 4% WHAT ARE THESE
PERCENTAGES TRANSLATE WHEN IT.
COMES TO ACTUAL DOLLARS. I
DON'T KNOW WHEN THE CODE WAS
READ. AND I CAN PULL THAT
NUMBER HAVE IT TO YOU HERE IN A
IN A MATTER OF SECONDS I DON'T
HAVE THAT AT MY FINGERTIPS
RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS THE-
SPECIFIC ALLOCATIONS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY. GOING FORWARD IN THE IN
THE PLAN. AND THEN I HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION IN REGARDS TO
THE DIFFERENCE THE FOR ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES- IS THAT ALSO
SOMETHING THAT IS- DETERMINE
AND CODE- I MEAN THIS OR WAIT
TOO EXPANDED THE ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES- UNDER- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I MEAN I KNOW WE
HAVE FIFTY TO SEE AS FOR MS F.
W.'S THREE AND EIGHT EYES AND
FIVE L. P. A.'S- BUT- I. JUST
YOU KNOW I KNOW THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT NEED IS WHAT WHAT'S
THE CRITERIA OR ELIGIBILITY TO.
BE ABLE TO COME TO BECOME ONE
OF THE AN- ENTITY UNDER ABOUT
ONE OF THE FOUR. AGAIN THOSE
ARE ESTABLISHED UNDER FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW AND THE ENTITIES
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA ARE GRANDFATHERED
IN- AS FAR AS- THEY'RE THE
THEY'RE JUST LOCKED IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- THERE WOULD HAVE TO
BE A PROCESS TO DETERMINE THAT
D. DESIGNATION- THAT GOES
THROUGH A SERIES OF. OF STEPS
THAT AGAIN IS OUTLINED IN STATE
CO TO- REMOVE A SINGLE ENTITY
AND REPLACE IT WITH ANOTHER AT
THIS STAGE WE ARE NOT ADDING
ADDITIONAL OR MORE WILL WE GET
THE DISMAL- ENTITIES BECAUSE
ALL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
COVERED- BASED ON OUR CURRENT-
SPREAD ISSUES B. G. AGENCIES.
SO JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTOOD IT CLEARLY IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S- PLACED
INTO STATE AND FEDERAL LAW ALSO
IS IT THAT THE STATE JUST KIND
OF- GOES WITH WHAT WHAT FEDERAL
LAW IS ASKING FOR AND WE ABIDE
BY IT OR- I GUESS I NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARIFICATION
ON THAT. HOW IT WAS MORE ABOUT
AS C. S. B. G. WAS IT IS AND
REGIONALLY ADMINISTERED HERE AT
THE STATE- ITS LONGSTANDING- A
CODE SECTION AS IT RELATES TO
WHO IS AND WHO IS NOT A C. S.
B. G. GRANDFATHER AGENCY. AND
IT GOES BACK TO- THE EARLY
SIXTIES AND THEN THE CHANGES
THAT HAVE FEDERAL CODE- UNDER
THE C. S. B. G. ACT. AND WHO
WILL BE IT WILL NOT BE
CONSIDERS HIS PROJECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT- TO MY MIND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'D BEEN LOOKED
AT- EIGHTY RECENT. TIME BUT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT. WE CAN
DEFINITELY RESEARCH AND GET
BACK TO YOU ABOUT. THANK YOU- I
ALSO WANTED TO ASK IS
CALIFORNIA MAXIMIZING THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT WE
RECEIVE- TO SEE S. B. G. IS-
OPPORTUNITY DUE TO IMPROVING
GETTING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. I
BELIEVE I WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE MAXIMIZING THE
DOLLARS THAT THE EVEN IF WE
COULD ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR OR THE ACTUAL
EXPENDITURE OF DOLLARS ARE WE
MAXIMIZING THAT. THAT'S MORE OF
A GENERAL QUESTION DID DID FROM
YOUR AND IF THERE'S IF YOU
BELIEVE BUT MAYBE WE COULD-
EXPAND THOSE DOLLARS- RIGHT. I
THINK THAT- WELL FIRST TO MY
HOME THE QUESTION WAS- WE THAT
CALIFORNIA DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXPAND ON THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THOSE ARE
ALLOCATED BASED ON- THE- US
CENSUS DATA TRACKING
INFORMATION THAT THAT YOU. WERE
EXIST THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO
THOSE ALLEGATIONS ARE LOCKED IN
BY THE FEDS. AS FAR AS- ARE WE-
ADMINISTERING THE DOLLARS IN
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE TO LOCAL
LEVEL- I WOULD LIKE TO BELIEVE
WE ARE I THINK WE ARE. I THINK
THAT THE REPORTING THAT COMES
UP FOR MARK RCCG AGENCY SHOWS A
SIGNIFICANT EIGHT SUPPORT
SERVICES AND OUTCOMES- TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA'S THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I WOULD INVITE-
MISTER KNIGHT. AND MR DEVICE
POTENTIALLY TO SHARE. ANY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES OR OR
THOUGHTS ON THAT AS WELL IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM THEM-
BUT FROM THE DEPARTMENT'S POINT
OF VIEW WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BOTTOM UP PROGRAM- CCG IS
SERVING. WELCOME CALIFORNIANS-
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE AS THEY
ARE BROKEN OUT BY AGENCY AND BY
THEIR LOCAL. NEEDS AND THEIR
LOCAL NEEDS ASSESSMENTS. WHAT
ANY OTHER OF THE SPEAKERS LIKE
TO ADD TO THAT. I WILL JUST
MENTION A DAVID NIGHT OF
ACCOUNTABLE WE HAVE A REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL- FIFTY FIVE MILLION
UP FROM- THE FEDERAL OCS THIS
YEAR- IS IN THE BUDGET HAS BEEN
ORIGINALLY PUT IN ABOUT ONE TO
COMMITTEE SO. THERE IS A HOPE
TO EXPAND THE C. S. B. G.
RECORDS THAT IS SET BY THE
FANS. AND YOU KNOW THE MAJORITY
THE FLEXIBILITY DOES COME IN IN
THE DISCRETIONARY FUNDING OF
THE STATE YOU KNOW FOR THE
ABILITY TO CREATE A BE CREATIVE
AS A STATEWIDE. WELL THE
MAJORITY OF THE REST OF THE 90%
OF IT IS REALLY BASED ON THAT
AGENCY LEVEL SO I THINK GERMAN
WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE-
YEAH. THE ONE POINT I WOULD ADD
TO IS IT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THE FUNDING IS. DERIVED BASED
ON POPULATIONS AND A FORMULA
DRIVE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOWN TO THE STATE
AND- DOWN TO OUR LOCAL AGENCIES.
I WOULD I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT THAT AS FAR AS
MAXIMIZING THE WORD MAXIMIZING
THE FUNDING I WOULD SAY. THE
FLEXIBILITY OF C. S. B. G.
ALLOWS US TO MAXIMIZE WHATEVER
AMOUNT THE FUNDING WE GET
LOCALLY. WE'RE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
IT SO WE SPREAD OUR MONEY. IN
KERN COUNTY OUT AMONGST MANY
PROGRAMS- WHETHER IT BE MY GIRL
TURNER PAYMENT PROGRAM. OR VITA
PROGRAM- DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TO
USE CENTERS ARE FOOD BANKS WE
SPREAD THAT OUT LEVERAGE
AGAINST MANY OTHER STATE AND
FEDERAL PROGRAMS. AND BUILD THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ABLE TO
OPERATE. SO WE GET MAXIMUM
LEVERAGE OUT OF THE MONEY WE
GET FROM C. S. B. G. WE CAN
MAXIMIZE THAT- VERY STRONGLY
BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE AND MOVE THE MONEY
AROUND HOW WE SEE FIT LOCALLY.
THANK YOU AND- I DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT I WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMODORE AT KNOB SURVATION
THAT I MADE. SEVERAL MONTHS AGO
I WAS ACTUALLY REVIEWING THE
STATE PLAN. THE MOST RECENT ONE
THAT WAS AVAILABLE ON THE
INTERNET AND- WHAT WAY LONG
BEFORE THIS THIS HEARING AND-
ALSO WHEN AND KIND OF COME
PAIRED SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
STATE PLANS THAT WERE- ALSO
AVAILABLE ONLINE AND IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THERE'S VERY-
MINIMAL. CHANGE I THINK THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU TO MAXIMIZE PERHAPS I
DON'T KNOW MAYBE MAXIMIZES NOT
THE RIGHT WORD BUT- MAYBE
THERE'S MORE OPPORTUNITIES AND
THEY'RE FREE- YOU KNOW FULLY
AND THOROUGHLY- REVIEW THAT
THAT STATE PLAN IT'S JUST AN
OBSERVATION THAT I MADE THAT I
WANT TO PUT ON THE RECORD TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HELD. OKAY
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR SECOND
PANEL TO BEGIN THEIR
PRESENTATION- WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE FUNDED
AGENCIES- DO WE HAVE OVERHEAD
THE LAVA. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OPPORTUNITY CENTER ON THE LINE.
I AM HERE UNTIL OR WHAT SCARES
ME WELCOME. THANK YOU. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR OF TOTAL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS LOOK AT THE NOVEL
AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OPPORTUNITY CENTER WE ARE A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
AND- C. S. B. G. FUNDED
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS A
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY LOCATED
AND PROVIDING SERVICES AND
STANISLAUS MERCED AND MADERA
COUNTIES- EARLIER HOW THE
DISCUSSION ENSUED ABOUT-
MIGRANT SEASONAL FARMWORKERS
AND COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES.
AS WELL AS A TO OTHER TYPES OF
AGENCIES- I CAN REPORT TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT CBO SEE- WE ARE
NOT ONLY THE COMMUNITY ACTION
AGENCY AND STANISLAUS COUNTY
BUT WE ARE ALSO FUNDED BY C. S.
B. G. TO PROVIDE MIGRANT
SEASONAL FARMWORKERS SERVICES
IN STANISLAUS MERCED AND MADERA
SO WE KIND OF CHECK TO OF THOSE
BOXES. SORRY THIS HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR OVER FORTY TWO YEARS
AND AS I MENTIONED WE'RE IN THE
CENTRAL SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ONE
OF THE OF COURSE COMMUNITIES
AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA SO THE
CSPD FUNDING THAT WE DO RECEIVE
FROM CST IS VERY BENEFICIAL TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND NOT ONLY-
PROVIDING SERVICES. TO BREAK
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY BUT ALSO
TO BRING FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES CLOSER TO SELF
SUFFICIENCY. SOME OF THE AREAS
OF OUR FOCUS. WITH THE CSPD
FUNDS. TEND TO REVOLVE AROUND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PROGRAMS
REMEDIATION. COURSES LIKE ESL
AND GED PREPARATION. AS WELL AS
HUMAN SERVICES- SUCH AS- RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FOOD VOUCHERS
UTILITY ASSISTANCE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION ETCETERA ETCETERA.
DURING THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS- TO THE PANDEMIC- THERE
IS ONE PARTICULAR AVENUE OF
PERFORMANCE BUT CBO SEEING HAS
USED IT SINCE MAJI FUNDS THAT I
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
TODAY. AND THAT IS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CST CAL
PALPA CENTRAL VALLEY
OPPORTUNITY CENTER ANOTHER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
CALIFORNIA CALLED SUPPLIED INC
.ORG. THIS PARTNERSHIP AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE FOUR
ENTITIES BUT I MENTIONED- WE
WERE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE
UNNECESSARY TP ITEMS. TO
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- OUR ROLE
IN THAT TERRIBLE- PARTNERSHIP.
WAS HELPING SUPPLY BANK
DISTRIBUTE. THAT PPE ITEMS.
ARTICULATED ACTUALLY DISEASE
WITH THE USE OF OUR TRUCK
SCHOOL THAT WE OPERATE- WITH
THE HELP OF C. S. B. G. FUNDS.
SO OUR TRACKING STUDENTS WHO
WERE LEARNING REAL WORLD-
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS AND ALSO
HELPING THE COMMUNITIES AT THE
SAME TIME. BY OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH SUPPLY BANK- ENTAILED OF
CBSE PICKING UP BALLOTS OF PP
FROM THEIR WAREHOUSE. AND
DISTRIBUTING IT THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AS WELL AS THE
MOTHER LOAD UP IN THE
FOOTHILLS. AND OUR PARTICIPANTS
ARE STUDENTS TO QUALIFY UNDER
CCG WERE DRIVING THESE TRUCKS
LEARNING TO DRIVE- PICK UP
ITEMS ACRI BILLS OF LADING IS
GO THROUGH- WAY CENTERS. AND
ABLE TO BUILD THEMSELVES A
RESUME WITH SOME EXPERIENCE
OTHER THAN YOU KNOW DRIVING
AROUND THE ORDER DRIVING AROUND
ON THE HIGHWAY THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PICKING UP IN DELIVERING THESE
pNECESSARY ITEMS- TO- COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES. THROUGHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA. IN THE- MIGRANTS IN
FARMWORKERS WERE DEEMED AS-
LAST YEAR HELLO IN MY OPINION
THEY'VE BEEN ESSENTIAL FROM.
DAY ONE FROM THE EXISTENCE OF
THE FARM WORKER- HAVING COME
FROM A FARM WORKER BACKGROUND-
WHAT WITH MY PARENTS AND OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS- THIS PARTICULAR
POPULATION IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME AND IS VERY POOR TO CENTRAL
VALLEY OPPORTUNITY CENTER. AND
WITH THE USE OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET FUNDS- YOUR MARK FOR
MYERS IS A FORMER- WE'RE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THEM IN THE NEEDS-
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER TO
BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT- BACK TO
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PIPING SO- WE'RE REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS-
NECESSARY. PPE ITEMS DELIVERED
TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS- BY
ASCENTIAL WORKERS- THE
FLEXIBILITY OF CSPD. IS WHAT
ALLOWED THAT- LASTLY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK- FOR OTHER
OPENNESS TO THAT TYPE OF
PARTNERSHIP- I THINK THE- THE
DATA SPEAKS FOR ITSELF AND THEN
THE REAL WORK EXPERIENCE FOR
OUR STUDENTS HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
BENEFICIAL. A LOT OF THOSE
STUDENTS THAT WORD OF DRIVING
THOSE TRUCKS AND PICKING UP.
THOSE PP PALLETS- HAVE NOW GONE
TO WORK- AND IT'S A REGULAR
RELATIONSHIP IN A COLLABORATION
THAT I HOPE WILL CONTINUE IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU MR THE
NUMBER- NEXT WE HAVE EILEEN
UNIONS THE MINISTRY OF SERVICES
MANAGER FROM THE COUNTY OF LA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
AM I MEAN IF COULD STEAL
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
MANAGERS WORKING FOR THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES ALSO
KNOWN AS DPSS. I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFIED TODAY.
YOUR INTEREST IN THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BACHRACH PROGRAM
INCLUDING THE LOCAL COUNTY
EXPERIENCE AS THE TYPICALLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE STATE CLASS. I
THANK BACKGROUND DPS. RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR NCCPG FUNDING.
WHICH IT DISTRIBUTES TO OVER
FORTY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDES A
WIDE ARRAY OF VIEWS BG SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY COMMUNITY. THE PURPOSE
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY IF
YOU DO PROGRAM IS TO ASSIST LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH ACHIEVING SELF SUFFICIENCY
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF SERVICES
UNDER THE FOLLOWING SIX CORE
SERVICE CATEGORIES WHICH ARE.
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES CHILD AND
FAMILY DEVELOPMENT SERVICES
EMERGENCY SERVICES ABOUT THE
FINAL THURSDAY. LEGAL SERVICES
AND SERVICES FOR SENIORS AND
DISABLED ADULTS. HE SAYS THREE.
SIX POINT MILLION IN FEES BG
ANSWER PROGRAM THAT'S TWENTY.
THE FUNDS FOR YEARS TO THIRDS
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
PERSONS WAY BEEN FIVE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED FAMILIES. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. FOR MORE
DETAILS ON THE OUTCOMES EIGHT
ACTUALLY THAT WAS PROVIDED TO
YOU. ADDITIONALLY THAT'S IF WE
KEEP OUR ALLOW THE CBO SNAPPER
TUNA THE LEVERAGE OTHER SOURCES
OF FUNDING TO COMPLEMENT THE
SERVICES PROVIDED TO LAUGH AND
WOOD COUNTY COMMUNITY. THERE
WAS DEFINITELY A COLDER
NINETEEN THEY'RE PACKED ON THE
YEAR'S BUDGET PROGRAM NOW A.
COUNTY. SOME OF THE CBO SEX
FRIENDS THAT THEY WERE
EXPERIENCING AN INCREASED
DEMAND FOR FOOD SERVICE PRESS
FIVE MORE THAN 30% DURING THE
PANDEMIC. EVEN WITH MANY
GROCERY STORE OPTIONS. ARE SOME
INDIVIDUALS WE'RE JUST NOT ABLE
TO GO OUT TO PURCHASE A
NECESSITY. THEREFORE AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING WAS
PROVIDED TO THE CBO IS FOR THE
EXPANSION OF FOOD SERVICES. TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASINGLY TURNED
UP ON SENATE. THE CBO ALSO
EXPRESSED THAT THE COMMUNITY
NEEDED MORE WRAPAROUND AND I'M
THE COMMAND TYPE SERVICES. TO
CONNECT CLIENTS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
RESOURCES TO MEET THEIR
MULTIPLE NAY. THEREFORE WE HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO ENHANCE THAT
COMES YOUR BG WEBSITE WITH
RESOURCE GUIDE BASED ON SERVICE
CATEGORIES AND HAVE PROMOTED A
CULTURE REFERRAL AND CASE
MANAGEMENT. WITH ALL OF THIS
YEAR CBO AGENCIES. AND WEBER
PROGRAM WE HAVE SUCCESS STORIES.
SOME FEMALES EXPRESSED THAT
DURING THE PEPPERMINT ALSO
BECAUSE IT INCREASES FOR
AFFORDABLE AND DEPENDABLE CHILD
CARE. A CLIENT FROM THE BOYS
AND GIRLS CLUB OF WHERE YOUR-
DATA BUT SHE LOST HER SISTER
DIRT PARTICLES NINETEEN.
PERSONS TURN LEFT BEHIND FOUR
CHILDREN. SHE WAS NOW FACED
WITH HAVING TO FIND AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE. SHE EVENTUALLY
FOUND FREE CHILDCARE AT THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF WHEN
YOU'RE WITH WITH THE HELP OF
YOUR FIJI FONG. SHE WAS
APPRECIATIVE AND GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF THE RESOURCES THAT THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB WOULD BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE HER. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF THE PROGRAM'S
SUCCESS IS THAT OF A SIXTY ONE
YEAR OLD MALE THE FEDERAL BALLY
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY. HE WAS
EXPERIENCING MULTIPLE HEALTH
ISSUES. AND THE CARE GIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE LEFT TO
HIS AGENT WHY. THE YWCA OF
CENTRAL VALLEY WAS ABLE TO
ASSIST THE COUPLE BECAUSE THEY
WORK THEY WERE OVERWHELMED WITH
UTILITY EXPENSES AND MEAL
PREPARATION. THEY OFFERED
REFERRALS TO ASSIST WITH A
MONTHLY UTILITY PAYMENT AND
ASSISTED WITH THE APPLICATION
FOR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
THE COUPLE ALSO RECEIVED. A
MAIL FROM THIS AGENCY. AND
OCCSIONALLY A LOT OF STATE
HOMELESS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIM TRUCKERS FUNDING CAME TO
CALIFORNIA TO CLEAN PROVIDER.
SHE WAS HAVING DIFFICULTY
ADJUSTING TO BEING IN THE STATE
I HAVE NO FAMILY SUPPORT. WITH
THE HELP OF CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES AT SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SIX PRACTICE BANNER IN THE
SOUTH OF ANGELES AREA SHE WAS
ABLE TO RECEIVE ASSISTANCE WITH
APPLYING FOR COUPLE WORK HOW
FRANCE ADMITTED CALPERS FUND.
WELL THERE AND SHE ALSO RECEIVE
STABLE EMERGENCY HOUSING MEALS
AND CLOTHING. IN CLOSING I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THESE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES
OF THE GREAT WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE BY COMMUNITY AGENCIES.
FIFTY S. B. G. CRAP IS A
FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING TO
PROVIDES CRITICAL AND LIFE
CHANGING PROGRAMS TO THE LOW
INCOME CITIZENS OF THE COUNTY.
AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST POVERTY. FINALLY WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF OUR STATE
LEADERS. THE WORK YOU DO IN THE
CAPITAL OF THE SUPPORT TO
PURSUE A PROVIDE THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO THOSE MOST IN NEED.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
DEDICATION TO EVERYTHING IS B.
G. PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS AN S. AND NEXT WE HAVE A
SANDRA VALDEZ THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR LOS ANGELES NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIAN COMMISSION. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR CALDERON
CARE HER TADO VICE CHAIR DAVIES
THANKS JERRY JONES AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY AND SURE
ABOUT HOW THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES BLOCK GRANT NATIVE
AMERICANS SET ASIDE FUNDS
SUPPORT LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
COMMUNITIES. MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER VALDEZ AND TODAY I'M
CALLING IN FROM THE ANCESTRAL
AND UNCEDED TERRITORY OF THE
TONGA QUICHE TO TANYA AND SHE
MATCH PEOPLE. WHAT IS NOW KNOWN
TODAY AS LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LOS ANGELES CITY COUNTY
NATIVE AMERICAN INDIAN
COMMISSION AND THE COMMISSION
SELF GOVERNANCE BOARD. THE
COMMISSION IS A JOINT CITY OF
LA COUNTY OF LA ADVISORY
COMMISSION THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO TO SUPPORT
ELOISE AMERICAN INDIAN AND
ALASKA NATIVE COMMUNITY. THE
LARGEST OF ANY COUNTY IN THE
COUNTRY. WHILE WE ARE THE
LARGEST NATIVE COMMUNITY IN THE
COUNTRY MUCH OF THE WORK OF THE
COMMISSION IS CENTERED AROUND
COMBATING SYSTEMIC AND
STRUCTURAL RASCHER OF NATIVE
PEOPLE HISTORIES AND CULTURE.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE WE ARE
VISIBLE AS A POPULATION AND OUR
NEEDS AND CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED. ORDING TO RESEARCH
RECENT RESEARCH BY ELIMINATED
72% OF AMERICANS RARELY
ENCOUNTER RECEIVE INFORMATION
IF PEOPLE'S. 87% OF STATE
HISTORY SANDERS DO NOT MENTION
IN AMERICAN HISTORY AFTER
NINETEEN HUNDRED. AND CLOSE TO
A QUARTER OF ALL STATES MAKE NO
MENTION OF NATIVE AMERICANS AND
THEIR K. THROUGH TWELVE
CURRICULUM AT ALL. THIS
CONTRIBUTES TO MAINSTREAM
AMERICA BELIEVING THAT NATIVE
AMERICANS ARE PASTOR DWINDLING
POPULATION. A RACING OUR
HISTORY LEADS TO AN ERASURE OF
OUR CURRENT REALITIES AND
NEEDS. THIS IS BECAUSE IT
CAUSES A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING
OF THE TRAUMA THIS HISTORY IS
BECAUSE AND THE PERVASIVE
SOCIOECONOMIC. AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES BORN OUT OF THAT
TRAUMA. IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
NATIVE PEOPLE ARE THREE POINT
FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN NON
HISPANIC WHITES TO LIVE IN
HOUSEHOLDS WITH AN INCOME BELOW
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. WITH
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN THREE
URBAN NATIVE CHILDREN LIVING IN
HOUSEHOLDS WITH INCOME BELOW
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
NATIVE PEOPLE IN L. A. COUNTY
ARE FIVE POINT FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS. ACCORDING TO
THEIR SHARE OF THEIR POPULATION
MAKING NATIVE PEOPLE THE RACIAL
ETHNIC GROUP MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
HOMELESSNESS AND L. A. COUNTY.
COMPARED TO THE GENERAL
POPULATION AMERICAN INDIANS
ALASKA NATIVE IN L. A. COUNTY-
ALSO DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY ADDICTION OR
FORECLOSURE. UNINHABITABLE
LIVING ONDITIONS AND MEDICAL
DISABILITY AS REASONS FOR
HOMELESSNESS. AND IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT OVER 90% OF OUR
IN HOUSE AMERICAN INDIANS AND
ALASKA NATIVES IN L. A. COUNTY
ARE UNSHELTERED. I COULD GO ON
ABOUT THE OTHER ALARMING AND
HEARTBREAKING STATISTICS THAT
IMPACT NATIVE PEOPLE IN L. A.
COUNTY. HOWEVER I WANT TO TAKE
THE REST OF MY TIME TODAY TO
SURE ABOUT HOW THE C. S. B. G.
NATIVE AMERICANS OUTSIDE FUNDS
ARE BEING UTILIZED BY OUR
INCREDIBLE SUB RECIPIENT
AGENCIES. TO SUPPORTER NATIVE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES. THE COMMISSION
GOVERNANCE BOARD HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERING COMMUNITY SERVICE
BLOCK GRANTNATIVE AMERICANS
THAT ASIDE FUNDS SINCE THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES. FOR
NEARLY THIRTY YEARS THESE FUNDS
HAVE PROVIDED CRITICAL SERVICES
TO LOS ANGELES IS AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
COMMUNITIES. AS YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT KNOW. THERE ARE NO
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN
WHAT IS NOW KNOWN AS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AS A RESULT OF
NOT HAVING FEDERAL RECOGNITION
THE LOCAL TRIBES OF L. A.
COUNTY ARE AN ELIGIBLE FOR MANY
OF THE FUNDS DEDICATED AND
DIRECTED AT TRACKS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE VERY FEW
DOLLARS- THAT COME INTO URBAN
AREAS LIKE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
FOR URBAN NATIVE PEOPLE. AS
SUCH THE CSP JEANETTE AMERICANS
OUTSIDE FUNDS OR SOME OF THE
ONLY DEDICATED DOLLARS TARGETED
L. A. COUNTY URBAN AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
POPULATION. TODAY THESE FUNDS
ALLOW COMMUNITY MEMBERS LIVING
IN POVERTY TO OBTAIN MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES AND CULTURALLY
SUPPORTIVE SETTINGS. CURRENTLY
WE FUNDS THREE SEPARATE
CIVILIAN AGENCIES ALL THREE
AGENCIES ARE TRUSTED AMERICAN
EIGHT AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN
NATIVE SERVING ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO SERVICE AREAS ARE THE
ENTIRE COUNTY OF LA. THE NATIVE
COMMUNITY IN L. A. COUNTY IS
NON GEOGRAPHICALLY CONCENTRATED
HOWEVER WE SEE TAT THAT OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WILL TRAVEL
ACROSS THE COUNTY I COUNTY
LARGER THAN DELAWARE TO SEEK
SERVICES AT A TRUSTED NATIVE
SERVING ORGANIZATION. TODAY OUR
THREE SUB RECIPIENT AGENCIES
UTILIZE ESG FUNDING TO PROVIDE
A VARIETY OF SERVICES TO OUR
INCOME ELIGIBLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. INCLUDING CONGREGATE
MEALS TO ELDERS AS WELL AS
OTHER NUTRITIONAL SERVICES.
RENTAL ASSISTANCE UTILITY
ASSISTANCE SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND
EMERGENCY CLOTHING FOR STUDENTS
AS WELL AS TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES. ALL OF THESE SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED AND CULTURALLY
SUPPORTIVE SETTINGS. TO
OCCURRENCE OF RECIPIENT
AGENCIES ALSO ADMINISTER
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
CARE SPENDING TO SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND ACTED BY CODE NINETEEN.
SHARES THE PANDEMIC OUR
COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING INSECURITY
AND UNEMPLOYMENT BUT THESE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL AND
ALLOWING US TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES.
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE OF THE
TEMPORARY INCREASED INCOME
ELIGIBILITY FOR THESE FUNDS WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SERVE A
GREATER PORTION OF OUR
COMMUNITY WHO ARE IN NEED BUT
NORMALLY NOT ELIGIBLE FOR C. S.
B. G. SERVICES. RECENTLY ONE OF
OUR SERVERS HAVE BEEN AGENCIES
WITH ZERO WAS ABLE TO UTILIZE
THE S. B. G. FUNDING TO ASSIST
A COMMUNITY MEMBER AND HER
PLANE SECURE WHAT COULD
POSSIBLY. BE LIFE ON HOUSING
STABILITY. THIS PARTICULAR
CLIENT WAS IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE WITH MOVING COSTS
PER UNIT SHE HAD FOUND THAT
WOULD TAKE HER SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER. THIS IS AN ACHIEVEMENT
IN OF ITSELF AS SHE LIKELY HAD
TO BE PLACED ON A SECTIN EIGHT
WAITLIST. THROUGH A LOTTERY
THEN WAIT FOR ON THAT LIST FOR
SIX TO TEN YEARS AND THEN ON
TOP OF THAT FIND A LANDLORD
WILLING TO TAKE ABOUT YOUR AND
THE INCREDIBLY COMPETITIVE.
RENTAL MARKET THAT IS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I AM WHEN IT
SEEMS SHE HAD MADE IT THROUGH
ALL POSSIBLE BARRIERS. I WAS
ABLE TO AFFORD RENT. SHE COULD
NOT MANAGE A SECURITY POP
DEPOSIT WHICH WAS FOUR TIMES
FOR MONTHLY RESPONSIBILITY. ARE
SUB RECIPIENT AGENCY WAS ABLE
TO QUICKLY WORK WITH HER
LANDLORD AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
WITH MOVING COSTS. TODAY HER
AND HER FAMILY HAVE STABLE AND
SECURE HOUSING. AND LIKELY WILL
FOR MANY MANY YEARS TO COME. IN
ADDITION TO AN EXAMPLE OF A
SERVICE ACCESS. I ALSO WANTED
TO SHARE ABOUT HOW THE ABILITY
TO LEVERAGE THE S. B. G.
FUNDING HAS LED TO A HUGE WIN
FOR US THIS PAST WEEK. THAT
ALMOST CERTAINLY ALLOW US TO
SERVICE MORE OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IMPACTED BY
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSECURITY AND THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY MEASURE J. WAS APPROVED-BY L. A. COUNTY VOTERS. TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF SYSTEMIC
RACISM BY PROVIDING FUNDING.
FOR ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION AND DIRECT
COMMUNITY INVESTMENTS. MEASURE
J. CALL FOR THE ALLOCATION OF
10% OF THE COUNTY'S
UNRESTRICTED LOCALLY GENERATED
REVENUES. TO BE INVESTED IN
CAREFIRST JAILS LAST WORK.
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE COUNTY
SOLICITED INTERNAL COUNTY
PROPOSALS FOR MEASURE J.
FUNDING THE REQUESTED PERFECT
PROPOSALS REFER PROGRAM
ENHANCEMENTS AND OR EXPANSIONS.
THE COMMISSION SUBMITTED A
PROPOSAL FOR THESE FUNDS
BECAUSE WE ADMINISTER C. S. B.
G. LAST WEEK ON AUGUST TENTH
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
APPROVED YOUR ONE SPEND THE
YEAR ONCE SPENDING PLAN WHICH
INCLUDES. FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO EXPAND AND ENHANCE
THE SBG FUNDED SERVICES THAT
ADDRESS NATIVE AMERICAN HOUSING
INSECURITY AND HOMELESSNESS
THIS IS NEARLY TWO TIMES OUR
ANNUAL C. S. B. G. AWARD.
FINALLY I WANT TO SHARE CODE I
WANT TO SHARE CODE BECAUSE THEY
I WANTED TO BUT I'M UNABLE TO
ON THOSE PLATFORMS ARE GONNA
SEND EVERYBODY THE LINK. BUT
THIS VIDEO THAT I'LL BE SHARING
WITH YOU ALL I WAS ABLE TO HELP
PRODUCE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
NETWORK OF LA BASED AMERICAN
INDIANS. AND THEY AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS- WHILE NO CSU
DOLLARS WERE SPENT DIRECTLY ON
THIS PROJECT MY TIME WORKING ON
THIS PROJECT WAS PARTIALLY
SUPPORTED BY C. S. B. G. AND IS
A GREAT EXAMPLE OF HOW
INCREDIBLE THE ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE THE S. B. G. FUNDING
IS. THIS PSA WAS DEVELOPED IN
THE SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY IT
WASSHARED ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
THEN RE SHARED THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
ALSO ABLE TO SECURED SECURED
EARNED MEDIA PLACEMENT ON KABC
SEVEN LA THE NETWORK GRANITE
DURING PRIME TIMES FOR MONTHS.
FOR MONTHS IN LATE SUMMER AND
EARLY FALL TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS
TRULY A LABOR OF LOVE AND
REMINDED OUR COMMUNITY TO
COMMIT TO SAY PRACTICES DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. FOR ANCESTORS.
FOR A FAMILIES FOR FUTURE.
SORRY AND FINALLY WHEN I WAS
PREPARING FOR THIS TESTIMONY. I
WAS THINKING ABOUT HOW THIS
YEAR'S BG PROGRAM. IS DECADES
AHEAD OF ITS TIME IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING HOW EFFECTIVE
CHANGES DRIVEN BY COMMUNITY.
THE COSBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ELIMINATED HOW CRITICAL IT IS
TO WORK WITH TRUSTED MESSENGERS
AND ORGANIZATIONS TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AND OTHER
PROVIDE RECENT ISSUES. CSPD HAS
UNDERSTANDING SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. FRAWLEY COUNTIES
NATIVE COMMUNITIES THAT HAS
PROVEN TO BE ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS ABOUT THIS PROGRAM. OUR
SEVERAS TO BE AN AGENCIES ARE
TRUSTED NATIVE SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT KNOW HOW TO
BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
CLIENTS TO ALLEVIATE POVERTY
AND INCREASE SELF SUFFICIENCY
AND C. S. B. G. ALLOWS THEM TO
DO THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE. ABOUT THE C. S. B. G.
PROGRAM AND HOW TO SUPPORT OF
THE NATIVE COMMUNITY AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I LOOK FORWARD
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE FOR ME. THANK YOU
MISSPELLED AS- NOW I'D LIKE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE
COMMENT CARE COMMENTS HAVE A
COMMENT OKAY THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR I JUST WANTED THANK- WHAT
HIT THE NAVA AND I LEAD KNOWING
YES AND ALEXANDER VALDEZ
FURTHER TESTIMONY TODAY AND OF
COURSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU DO WELL IN
THE COMMUNITIES AND- AND YOU
KNOW EVERYBODY ELSE SO- ONE
LEAVE IT TO THAT BUT WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE- THE WHOLE THE
WORK THAT YOU DO ON THE
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU SENATOR-
AND I GUESS I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION FOR ANYONE OF THE
PANELISTS- ARE THERE ANY WAYS
THE LEGISLATURE CAN HELP YOU TO
SERVE YOUR POPULATIONS MORE
EFFECTIVELY. AND ANYBODY CAN
ANSWER THAT- ALEXANDRA ANILINE
JORGE. ALEXANDRA'S I THINK
TRYING YEAH I WILL- AND I
NEEDED YOU KNOW HEARING. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OH SORRY YEAH THIS IS
ALEXANDER VALDEZ- I WILL STICK
TO JUST SHARING THAT- DURING
THIS PANDEMIC- THE INCREASE OF
THE INCOME ELIGIBILITY 22100%
HAS PROVEN- REALLY HELPFUL FOR
THE HIGH COST OF LIVING
LOCATION LIKE L. A. COUNTY- AND
IT'S JUST. LIKE I SAID IT'S
MANY WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SERVE
MORE PEOPLE- DUE TO THIS A
TEMPORARY INCREASE IN INCOME
ELIGIBILITY WHICH I BELIEVE
EXPIRES AT THE END OF SEPTEMBER.
OKAY THANK YOU. LOOKING AT WHAT
GO AHEAD I'M SORRY IF I COULD
FEEL FROM L. A. COUNTY- YES I'D
LIKE TO ECHO WITH MISSPELLED
THAT SAID REGARDING THE- THE
INCREASED OUR NUMBERS AND I
DOUBTS FOR CLIENTS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO SIR AND ALSO AS IT
RELATES TO ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT'S ALWAYS I WOULD ALWAYS BE
APPRECIATED APPRECIATED TO
ASSIST THESE AGENCIES. EXPAND
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SERVICES
TO- TO ALL THOSE. IN NEED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I WOULD JUST
CHECK OUT THE SAME COMMENTS I
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND AN
OPEN INVITATION TO ANY MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
COMMITTEE- THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AS SOON AS WE DO FUNDS IN
ACTION- YOU HAVE AN OPEN
INVITATION TO- STAND SOMERSET
MADERA COUNTIES- ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU JORGE. OKAY SO WILL
NOW ALLOW FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT-
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM-
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. OKAY I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM DO WE HAVE
ANYONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION I WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE. PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
WE DON'T. DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON
THE LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS OPERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE IF AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY MA'AM OKAY- ALL
RIGHT WELL I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK OF ALL OF OUR
PARTICIPANTS- AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IS FOR HER- THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY- AS OUR STATE
CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT POLICIES
TO ADDRESS POVERTY. MESS HERE
DIRECTLY FROM THOSE ON THE
GROUND HER CURRENTLY DOING THE
WORK. NUMBER SEVEN IT FROM THE
TESTIMONY TODAY. THAT THE
PERSONALITY OF C. S. B. T.
FUNDING ALLOWS FOR DIRECT AND
IMMEDIATE. SUPPORT THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT BE POSSIBLE FOR
MANY COMMUNITIES I LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING HOW THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY CSPD FINDING
CONTINUE TO ADAPT TO MEET THE
CHANGING NEEDS OF OUR STATE.
THANK YOU THIS CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING. GREAT HEARING. GOOD
INFORMATION.